four days ago AOC said something really
dumb and wrong
that alone of course would not be
particularly newsworthy since the news
typically Endeavors to present stories
that are unusual but this particular
viral diatribe caught my attention not
because aoc's argument is wrong but
because
it is perfectly wrong take a listen
I think it's important to state that
that abortion is an economic issue
forcing poor and working-class people
to give birth against their will against
their consent against their ability to
provide for themselves or a child is a
profound economic issue and it's
certainly a way to keep a Workforce
basically conscripted to large-scale
employers and two employers to be to
work more against their will to take
second and third jobs against their
desire and their own autonomy and so the
idea that
um that abortion and access to abortion
is somehow not a profound and Central
economic and class issue and class
struggle is certainly something that I
think a person who's never had to
contend uh with the ability to carry a
child
um you know it belies that perspective
so aoc's argument is that abortion is an
important tool of the working class of
the proletariat to shake off the bonds
of its capitalist oppressors
but if that's the case
then how come all the big corporations
are subsidizing it
how come after the Dobbs decision came
down over ruling Roe v Wade how come
Google and Walmart and Amazon and pretty
much every big company in the country
sent out a press release promising to
reimburse the costs of female employees
who want to travel out of state to abort
their babies
abortion is a class issue but not in the
way AOC thinks actually in exactly the
opposite way abortion much like AOC is a
tool of wealthy capitalists to squeeze
more productivity and therefore more
money out of their labor force women who
have babies take more time off
during pregnancy during maternity leave
even after they come back to work if
they come back to work mothers are more
distracted with their kids doctor's
appointments and little league and piano
recitals and all the sorts of things
that make them less ideal as automatons
churning out widgets in the factory for
Big Boss Penny bags it's much much more
efficient
from a money standpoint for the
capitalists to just encourage the women
and even even pay the women to kill
their kids so that they can get back to
the office and do more spreadsheets if
AOC had an ounce of introspection she
might stop to ask herself why pretty
much all of the wealthiest and most
powerful people in the country support
her why she gets such glowing treatment
in the corporate press why she gets
invited to all of the fancy events with
all the rich people why AOC rakes in
more big dollar campaign donations than
pretty much any politician of her
stature in the country
if AOC were really a renegade radical
fighting the evil and entrenched
capitalist establishment wouldn't you
expect that that establishment might not
fawn over her constantly
in reality
AOC is no Renegade she's no radical she
has certainly no threat to the system
the system attacks and silences and
prosecutes the only real people who
question or oppose it which is to say
conservatives the system will throw
Midwestern grannies in jail for taking
selfies in the capital rotunda it'll
raid Donald Trump's home on bogus
charges if he gets a little bit too high
up in the polls for 2024. but it will
never go after AOC at least as long as
she continues as we see now to do its
bidding the the class struggle
pseudo communist rhetoric coming out of
the left is so silly it's so ridiculous
so much of our political system is just
so fake
and I think it's becoming clearer and
clearer Donald Trump in particular
exposed a lot of it as being so fake
that what we see is two sides locked in
the struggle the far left and the far
right and they're fighting each other
that it's it's really just kind of a
charade very often it's kind of just
political theater and no matter what
happens in these battles the system the
kind of liberal establishment system
just sort of always wins you see this on
on certain issues they don't change no
matter who wins the left wins the right
wins we get more and more immigration
and more and more illegal immigration
for that matter
the left wins the right winds we just
keep offshoring our jobs the left winds
the right winds we keep getting more
globalist government whether that means
through trade treaties or whether that
means through giving more of our
national sovereignty away it just
doesn't seem to whether the left wins or
the right wins we get the exact same
foreign policy a lot of it just seems
like a charade I don't think the
political battle in this country is
between the Communists on one side and
the fascists on the other side I think
it's between two slightly different
variations of liberals you see this with
Nancy Pelosi Nancy Pelosi
who who came out and she said look we
need more mass migration because
not first because of Justice not first
because of these poor oppressed masses
yearning to be free but no because we
need someone to pick the crops
the fact is is that uh
we have a responsibility to secure our
border we also have a responsible to
recognize the importance of newcomers to
our nation right now the best thing that
we can do for our economy is to have
comprehensive immigration reform
we have a shortage of workers in our
country and you see even in Florida some
of the farmers and The Growers saying
why are you shipping these uh
immigrants up north we need them to pick
the crops down here
but that doesn't mean that we
don't recognize our moral responsibility
as well
notice what she leads with
she doesn't say we need more migrants in
this country because it's the right
thing to do or because American foreign
policy has destabilized Latin America or
because we're a Melting Pot and we know
she says we need more workers
she's making a capitalist argument
AOC is Shilling on behalf of the
capitalists to get women to sit in their
offices and and stay in their jobs and
not have the temerity to want to raise a
family
that's why the capitalists fund all of
these people
the dominant power in this country the
conservatives need to fight against is
actually not the Communists or even the
Socialists they're a problem too but
they're a relatively minor problem the
problem is the Liberals the Menace in
our country is not is not Joseph Stalin
it's Bill Clinton okay it's neoliberal
kind of crony capitalist money money
money above all else to the destruction
of to the detriment and I think really
destruction of communities families the
traditional way of life our national
borders for goodness sakes everything
it's money
the libs want the open borders
they've got a whole lot of reasons for
one of the open borders they say they've
got social reasons they certainly have
political reasons and electoral reasons
but the reason they got a lot of oomph
behind it is because open borders is
good for the crony capitalists you know
it's not it's not the the commies
exactly
and and conservatives I think we're
figuring this out now we've certainly
been figuring out a little bit more
since Trump we should not reflexively be
defending big corporations or even the
the free market as an as an end unto
itself markets are great market dynamics
can be a wonderful thing for economic
growth in a country but it's not the
be-all and end-all okay it's not an end
unto itself that would be putting the
cart before the horse the end of
government is Justice the end of
government is a flourishing Society
where we're all getting along and
growing and living together in in a good
country
okay we want we want the general welfare
we want the common good we want to live
in a nice place we were talking about
this a week or two ago you would much
rather be a poor man in a good Society
than a rich man in a society falling
apart
because even your wealth is contingent
on
the stability and flourishing of your
Society
okay if you're a rich man in Afghanistan
well you're probably not going to stay a
rich man very long because the Taliban
is going to show up and take your money
okay that that's that's what we need to
focus on here
we need to stop I I remember when I was
coming up in politics when I was a
teenager first kind of learning about
politics the the Republicans and the
conservatives they just carried water
for big corporations even when the
corporations attacked us even when they
started to censor us you heard arguments
from people ostensibly on the right who
said well you know we can't regulate
Google the most most powerful company on
Earth we can't regulate that if you want
to if you don't want to be censored and
kicked out of the Public Square and
you're a self-governing republic that in
your formerly self-governing Republic
then just build your own Google yeah
that's that's a solution it's
Preposterous and it does nothing but
Advance the interests of what we would
call the left we do have more show
coming up though what we've got to get
to is uh a wrap a rap song from a Utah
State Senate candidate a republican Utah
State Senate candidate I have never
heard this rap song before but it's
music Monday
so my producer Ben Davies has has lined
up this song for me I can't wait to
listen to it that show is continuing
right now you don't want to miss it if
you're not a member click on the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]